[Applaudissements]
m
je regarde
mais
folie jeu
c'est beau
de diane employés
[Applaudissements]
et puis cette soirée tendue hier
également pour pour emmanuel macron
alors qu'il assistait à une
représentation de la pièce la mouche au
théâtre des bouffes du nord des dizaines
de personnes se sont rassemblées devant
le théâtre
je vous propose de revenir sur ces faits
avec clément hospital top a décidé
ces manifestants se ruent à l'intérieur
du théâtre des bouffes du nord prenant
par surprise les policiers déployés
devant l'établissement culturel
leur objectif perturber la virée
nocturne du chef de l'état alors qu
emmanuel macron et son épouse assiste à
une représentation théâtrale la
tentative d'intrusion a été très vite
maîtrisé
le chef de l'état sécurisé à l'intérieur
du théâtre pendant quelques minutes une
présence révélé quelques instants plus
tôt par le journaliste et militante
aboaf assis quelques rangées derrière le
président je suis actuellement au
théâtre des bouffes du nord métro la
chapelle trois rangées derrière le
président de la république
des militants sont quelque part dans le
coin et appelle tout le monde à
rappliquer quelque chose se prépare la
soirée risque d'être mouvementée selon
des sources judiciaires
le journaliste a ensuite été interpellé
et conduit au commissariat
ta aboaf est suspecté par la police et
des proches du président d'être à
l'origine de ce rassemblement
l'opposition restent partagés quant à
cette intrusion dans quel régime
sommes-nous pour qu'un président furieux
que des manifestants qui conspuent à
l'extérieur d'un théâtre fasse arrêter
un journaliste qui s'y trouvait et qui
avait osé communiquer sur sa présence le
président de la république
exfiltré goutal impopularité en pleine
capitale
faute de pouvoir argumenter ils exigent
la répression et l'arrestation d'un
journaliste il est sûr qu'un certain
nombre de personnes aujourd'hui pense
que ce sont par des actes de violence
des blocages violent on l'a vu avec les
locaux de la cfdt ou hier soir qu'ils se
feront entendre
je pense que ces agissements doivent
être condamnés mais surtout ils sont
inquiétants car il révèle une montée en
tension et c'est une montée en tension
permanente ininterrompue depuis
maintenant plus d'un an et demi
il faut bien dire que le gouvernement
par son comportement a contribué au fur
et à mesure du temps à cette montée des
tensions
si cela n'excuse pas les agissements
d'hier et d'avant-hier de l'autre côté
le groupe la république en marche
condamne fermement la tentative
d'intrusion dans le théâtre où se
trouvait emmanuel macron les auteurs de
ces agressions sèment la violence et la
discorde
nous les ferons reculer par le
rassemblement des français et la
solidarité
le président de la république est resté
jusqu'à la fin de la représentation aux
bouffes du nord
il n'a en aucun cas été exfiltré le
militante à abu hafs a été interpellé et
qu'on ne parle pas de journaliste en ce
44ème jour de grève
plusieurs autres actions ciblées ont été
menées hier par les opposants à la
réforme des retraites l'elysée affirme
que le président continuera à se rendre
à des représentations théâtrales et
condamne toute tentative d'intimidation
et je vous le rappelle un des
échauffourées ont eu lieu en fin
d'après-midi à la fin de l'acte ce
passif régit les jeunes alors pour avoir
plus de précisions sur ce qui s'est
passé sur ce qui se passe on va tout de
suite retrouvé au coeur de la
manifestation notre reporter estelle
charge
estelle donc bon soir le cortège on
disait est arrivée gare de lyon en fin
d'après-midi pour terminer ça marche
mais la situation s'est ensuite
compliqué qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire
oui exactement olivier en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le gros du cortège
vous l'avez dit elle s'est dispersé
devant la gare de lyon et un cortège
sauvage s'est ensuite refermée cortège
sauvage qui a déambulé tout au long du
boulevard diderot où des feux ont été
allumés en des barricades ont été
montées on a vu un scooter brûler une
voiture renversée au milieu du boulevard
et ce cortège sauvage est semble-t-il a
terminé à sa course ici où je me trouve
place de la nation et vous allez loin
derrière moi sur ces images de stéphane
puccini et il ya toujours une forte
présence policière aux croisements donc
entre la place de la nation et le
boulevard est diderot en tout cas ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que pour le
moment le calme est revenu dans le dans
ce quartier où je me trouve merci
beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions estelle farges donc en direct
à proximité de la gare de lyon à paris à
la fin du cortège de l'acte 62 des
gilets jaunes alors si la situation se
calme depuis quelques minutes du côté de
la gare de lyon je vous propose de
revenir sur les images de tension de ce
début de soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vous en parlait
c'est bon dieu
de diana fois les
[Musique]
un peu
[Applaudissements]
parfois
et aurélie roe de la france vraiment et
florian philippot des patriotes nous ont
rejoints sur ce plateau bonsoir alors
effectivement une journée qui s'est
globalement plutôt bien passé puis ces
échauffourées
ce soir gare de lyon est au des déçus
étonné non je pense que effectivement
les mouvements continus ça ne s'arrête
pas depuis un an et demi donc on ne peut
pas être étonné déçus puisque ça donne
une triste image de la france encore une
fois ce soir alors florian philippot il
ya quelques jours le président de la
république a effectivement attiré
l'attention sur la déontologie policière
il va demander qu'une réflexion soit
faite à ce sujet là effectivement il ya
un problème
aujourd'hui quand on voit les images
qu'on a vu avec la question du maintien
de l'ordre en france selon vous où il ya
un sérieux problème
bon les policiers et les gendarmes
d'ailleurs aussi sont épuisés ça il faut
quand même en tenir compte s'il voulait
quand on parle de ces sujets là quand
vous êtes vous même épuisés parce que ça
fait 15 mois que vous êtes sûr
solliciter plus le contexte et rory ce
qu'on connaît bien
eh bien vous ne réagissez pas forcément
de la même manière quand vous avez tous
vos moyens et tout votre lucidité on va
dire en état normal mais il y a eu le
pouvoir a joué avec le feu pendant des
mois et des mois
insistant sur une doctrine très durs
contre les manifestants on a eu des
vraiment des dérapages inadmissibles des
mutilations même des morts et ça n'est
pas digne là aussi d'une démocratie
comme la france alors ça n'excuse en
rien les violences en face parce qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup de policiers qui ont
été violentées ou blessés mais bien sûr
que la france pendant ces mois et depuis
des mois ne donne pas un bon exemple au
monde et est que le gouvernement a mis
beaucoup d'huile sur le feu alors ça
fait une semaine qui commence à réaliser
qu'il ya un problème
honnêtement c'est très très tard ça fait
des mois et des mois qu'on tire la
sonnette d'alarmé et c'est assez
hallucinant de voir que seulement
maintenant le pouvoir semble s'en rendre
compte
alors aurelio on a vu sur les images en
direct sur rt france des hommes habillés
en noir avec des casques cac voulait
lancer effectivement des projectiles sur
les forces de l'ordre michel onfray sur
ce plateau il y à il ya quelques jours
disait que personne ne désignait
clairement qu'ils étaient les casseurs
et du coup effectivement on englobait
les gilets jaunes
tous comme étant des casseurs quel est
votre regard est ce que vous partagez
cette analyse de michel roy je l' ai dit
à plusieurs reprises il y a des gilet
jaune qui manifestent et qui ont des
véritables revendications et il y a un
groupe de black blocks pour les nommer
qui viennent là non pas pour lutter pour
leurs compatriotes dans un esprit de
manifestation mais pour casser et ses
black blocks nuisent gravement à l'image
des gilet jaune et je trouve
inadmissible qu'il soit encore là est
effectivement un bon à mon sens il faut
trouver des mesures policières sévère
pour pouvoir arrêter ces groupuscules
qui sont d'ailleurs dans tous les pays
européens et qui nuisent aux
manifestants lambda qui ne sont pas du
tout venu pour ça et c'est vrai qu'il ya
un amalgame qui est fait qui est
dramatique même de la part de l'opinion
publique qui explique que les jaunes
casse tout ce n'est pas vrai les gilets
jaunes sont là pour manifester on a
quelques exemples de manifestations qui
se sont bien passées pas forcément gilet
jaune mais même la manifestation des
retraites s'est plutôt bien passé le
problème de la manifestation des gilet
jaune c'est calme n'est absolument pas
encadrées comme les grandes
manifestations qui ont été emmenés par
des syndicats des syndicalistes
voilà aujourd'hui on a on à cette
problématique là et il faut il faut
lutter et pour revenir sur la question
des violences policières
et pour compléter ce que disait
monsieur philippot je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait arrêter avec
le terme de violences policières
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a une on a un
état on à la principale des libertés en
france notre sécurité et on se doit de
soutenir nos forces de police et de
gendarmerie
par contre les personnes dans la
gendarmerie ou dans la police qui ont
dès qu'ils ont commis des actes qui sont
impardonnables
il faut les punir et ce sont des fautes
des fautes graves mais il ne faut pas
jeter l'opprobre sur l'ensemble de notre
système de sécurité qu'est ce que
florian philippot les gilets jaunes au
fond auraient intérêt à davantage
s'organiser un peu à l'image de ces
syndicats très organisés qui connaissent
le fonctionnement avec un service
d'ordre tout ça fonctionne très bien est
ce qu'ils auraient intérêt ou alors le
mouvement du coup perdrait de sa
spontanéité
maintenant je pense que ça n'est pas
récent ça n'est pas possible c'est un
mouvement populaire qui alors qui ceci
dit ce qu'on en voit maintenant n'est
plus les plus grand chose par rapport à
ce qu'il a été il faut aussi le dire y
compris sociologiquement où les classes
moyennes malheureusement ne sont plus
beaucoup l'a effrayée en particulier par
les violences qu'on a vu des deux côtés
1 lors des manifestations mais est par
essence il peut pas à s'organiser comme
un syndicat ou un parti politique
en revanche moi ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est qu'on n'y a pas d'issue
politique proposée n'est pas de sortie
de crise si vous voulez et donc moi je
crains qu'on a est dans une situation où
ceux des scènes qu'on a vu comme il hier
au théâtre des manuels macron qu on l a
vu avec un peu plus tôt avec le siège de
la cfdt etc n'a pas eu d'ultra violence
mais il ya eu des choses anormales bon
je crains que ce genre de d'événements
se multiplient mais mais ça veut pas
dire qu'on en disant cela on ne justifie
rien on ne tolère rien on dit simplement
que quand on regarde objectivement les
choses on a un pouvoir qui ne veut pas
bouger
un pouvoir qui quoi que fasse le peuple
ou les manifestants sur les retraites ou
sur d'autres sujets ne veut rien bouger
du tout il ya au bout d'un moment ça en
démocratie ça coince complètement
et quand on ne peut plus manifester dans
les conditions normales parce qu'on se
prend du gaz lacrymo dès la première
demi-heure quand on a peur de manifester
que quand on a l'impression qu'on fait
grève et qu'on perd de l'argent en
faisant grève et que ça ne conduit à
rien pas la moindre concession
pas le moindre comprend
mais qu'est-ce qui reste au bout d'un
moment il va rester des formes
extrêmement violente et il faut pas
s'étonner il faut juste on peut taper du
poing disant il faut l'ordre il faut
arrêter avec ce désordre et cette
chienlit etc oui bien sûr on est tous
d'accord avec sa personne même le
désordre en imputant vivant de vivre
dans une société apaisée mais ça ne sert
à rien de taper du poing sur la table
tant qu'on n'a pas compris que il faut
régler le problème à la racine
c'est-à-dire d'avoir un pouvoir légitime
qui considère qu'il doit coproduire les
lois avec le peuple français et non pas
à sa place alors on en sera dans une
situation où on va avoir une situation
de rupture et donc une situation de
violence courir où vous lirez agir oui
je crois quand même qu'il y a eu des
avancées notamment avec la
transformation du conseil économique et
social et environnemental
on conseille de la participation
citoyenne je crois que c'est une avancée
en termes de concertation en termes de
démocratie participative qui n'avait
jamais eu lieu en france jusqu'à
maintenant cette troisième chambre
commence à exister mais je pense
effectivement que le gouvernement doit
aller plus loin et doit proposer
nouvelle façon de faire de la politique
c'était la promesse initiale d'ailleurs
d'emmanuel macron lorsqu'il a été élu et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est temps de
donner au français la possibilité de
s'intéresser à la constitution
effectivement de nos lois et la
proposition que moi je formule avec ce
conseil de la participation citoyenne
c'est de mettre en place le pouvoir
d'amendement du citoyen c'est à dire que
les lois soient partants concertation et
soit discuté avec le peuple avant
qu'elle arrive à l'assemblée nationale
vous les deux participations au sein de
notre démocratie représentative au tragi
florian philippot sur ce que vient de
dire aurelio ce serait mieux que rien
mais ça me paraît très petit très faible
la transformation du conseil économique
social environnemental en une autre
chose bon ou même ce droit d'amendement
moi je crois qu'il faut aller maintenant
clairement vers la démocratie directe
réels c'est-à-dire le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
j'ai toujours promu cet instrument qui
peut être encadrée parce qu'il faudrait
cinq cent mille signatures de personnes
inscrites sur les listes électorales
pour déclencher un référendum et les
gens sont mûrs pour ça ils réclament
cela et ça ça veut dire faire ou défaire
des lois soit même à tout niveau je
pense que c'est indispensable
il faut par ailleurs en parallèle sinon
ça ne sert pas à grand chose faire
sauter le verrou
de l'union européenne parce que tant que
vous n'avez pas votre souveraineté
nationale de toute façon même si vous
avez le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne où vous vouliez vous l'ayez
pas il ya des shows des pans entiers de
la démocratie qui ne sont plus sous
contrôle citoyen puisque c'est sous
contrôle bruxellois supranationale et
est donc bah vous ne gèreraient pas
grand-chose même avec la démocratie
directe et le référendum
donc tout faire les deux en même temps
redonné la souveraineté nationale au
pays et redonner la souveraineté
populaire au peuple français
et une fois qu'on aura fait ça alors je
prends le pari instantanée que la
situation me française va s'apaiser
considérablement que ce qui coince
aujourd'hui c'est que le peuple français
l'a compris qu'ils ne décident et plus
rien chez lui et qui n'étaient plus
respectées par ceux qui se prétendent
ses élites
en tous les cas tout ce qu'on observe
les journalistes qui sont sur le terrain
quand ils tendent le micro on entend il
ya plus de dialogue on peut plus parler
s'est terminée il ya un dialogue de
sourds vous l'expliquez comment relier
au jeu les sticks par le fait simplement
que les méthodes ont changé que la cie
la société a évolué aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens peuvent simplement se
renseigner sur internet avec les
nouvelles technologies les réseaux
sociaux et que cette évolution n'a pas
été du tout pris en compte par le
système politique actuel sert notre
système politique ne correspond pas du
tout à notre société actuelle
or aujourd'hui si l'on veut que les
français se sentent entendu écouté il
faut leur donner plus souvent la parole
et moi je pense que la communication et
la concertation avec les citoyens est
essentielle dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre la démocratie représentative ne
suffit plus par ailleurs nous allons
bientôt rentrer en élections municipales
on est en période d'élections
municipales et je crois que c'est aussi
un moment pour dire aux citoyens qui
nous écoutent d'aller voter pour ces
élections là parce que ces élections là
c'est le symbole même de ce qu'est la
démocratie participative
parce que vous le savez dans une commune
les luttes proximité c'est l'élu qui
rencontrent tous ses citoyens au
quotidien et je crois qu'il faut prendre
plus exemple sur les municipalités et
les maires et
maires des petites communes et que
l'état ça prenne en tout cas de cette
façon nouvelle de faire de la politique
ce qui nous permettra d'avoir aussi un
peu moindre défiance vis-à-vis de la
classe politique
alors on va continuer à changer à
l'issue de cet acte 62 des gilet jaune
mais avant on va revenir sur ces
tensions pour dans la capitale avec
jérôme rodriguez l'une des figures du
mouvement des gilets jaunes
jérôme rodriguez bonjour jérôme
rodriguez vous êtes en direct avec nous
sur rt français ce que vous nous
entendez oui je vous entends très bien
bonjour vous allez bien bien je vous
remercie alors jérôme rodriguez
qu'est ce que vous avez vécu sur place
est ce que vous avez assisté à des
violences particulières à l'issue de
l'accord un schéma stratégique qu'on
connaît depuis pas mal d'années avec un
attelage complet arrivée à la gare de
lyon la possibilité de sortir de
quelques points quelques points qu'ils
soient et les outils politiques se
retirent qui serait terre et qui
finissent par pierre dardenne à tout va
dans les gages
donc s'il y en a qui veulent seraient
ils veulent rester pour faire des
d'actes de violence qui du reste mais
ceux qui veulent sortir qu'on nous
laisse sortir de cette nasse parce que
ça commence à bien faire cette stratégie
de créer un climat de violence tout au
long de la manifestation
pour arriver à la fin du printemps est
un acte 62 qui s'est plutôt bien déroulé
globalement en cmu quelques
échauffourées dans la journée
je peux même vous dire que de par ma
personne j'ai eu énormément de compte ce
jour que toute la france hellion tanks
de parent est différent vous avez eu des
bus de mollesse de beauzelle pendant
quatre ans personne vous avez des gens
de toute la poterie sont venus à paris
il ya longtemps que j'avais pas vu il
m'a dit de gilet jaune comme ça et ça
fait bien plaisir ça remotive tout le
monde et on voit très bien que le
mouvement des légendes ne sied souffle
pas d'accord comme tour et prétendre
certains médias où certains membres du
gouvernement on est bien présent et on
continuera à être ce contre-courant
aujourd'hui on rejoignant un petit peu
ce qu'il y ait des personnes sur votre
bateau il ya quelques minutes
on veut aujourd'hui une démocratie
participative et qu'on veut qu'une tour
être entendu et on veut discuter qu'on
peut aussi ouvrir le dialogue
pour pouvoir accéder à l'ensemble de nos
revendications ça a été le mot d'ordre
aujourd'hui de cet acte 62 jérôme
rodriguez exactement voilà on est
et laissons les manifestations depuis le
5 décembre avec l'ensemble des syndicats
libres contre la réforme des retraites
et on a toutes manifestations si le le
le staff dit et je tiens à préciser que
j'ai énormément d'être indique ali sont
rejoints des différentes ligues erat et
est aujourd'hui au cap qui étaient aussi
présents dans la manif donc le mouvement
va se poursuivre la semaine prochaine
les embouteillages tant que nous aurons
un président qui gardera tu tapes
d'appliquer une politique de terreur à
coups de ltd de but il assuré écrira
l'histoire de france en lettres de sang
nous continuerons à être dans la rue
quoi qu'il advienne sauf dans une
démocratie la mère patrie des droits de
l'homme
ça doit être un pays qui doit être
exemplaire à l'écouté des citoyens et
aujourd'hui ça ne l'est pas donc qui
tuera être dans la rue se faire percuter
notre droit merci jérôme rodriguez
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt france alors je le
rappelle est aujourd'hui acte 62 des
gilets jaunes à paris selon les chiffres
de la préfecture
trente sept personnes interpellées
aujourd'hui à noter la dispersion
compliqué de la manifestation n'en parle
depuis tout à l'heure des gilets jaunes
qui sont arrivés il ya un peu plus d'une
heure au terminus de cette manifestation
la gare de lyon c'est là que la tension
est montée d'un cran entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre
jets de projectiles sur la police qui a
répliqué à coups de gaz lacrymogènes les
pompiers sont aussi intervenus à
plusieurs reprises pour éteindre des
feux voilà les dernières informations
sur la dispersion de cet acte 62 du
mouvement des gilets jaunes et pour en
parler justement avec nous sur ce
plateau aurélie gros et florian
philippot alors on a entendu la
détermination en même temps la colère
mais aussi la satisfaction jérôme
rodriguez de cette journée de cet acte
62 des gilets jaunes florian philippot
we will be notamment il a cité il a
mentionné la présence de bus venant de
différentes régions je suis le trésor il
a parlé de la mauvaise nouvelle
ça m'a fait plaisir bon bah ça c'est
vraiment un bon signe
enfin c'est un bon signe pour la
mobilisation je me sens plutôt de ce
côté là pour moi c'est un bon signe mais
c'est aussi un bon signe parce que ça
montre qu'il ya quand même des gens qui
qui bravent en quelque sorte la peur
d'aller manifester on est hallucinant de
devoir dire ça aujourd'hui en france à
on a peur d'aller militer mais c'est
vrai vous discutez avec les gens
beaucoup ont peur de physiquement
d'aller manifester à cause de tout ce
qu'on voit est ce qu'on entend nommé il
dit aussi que la fin manifestation est
gérée de manière traditionnelle et
manifestons même très pacifique sont
assez c'est vrai ça je confirme c'est
vrai ça se voit depuis soixante deux
actes et alors vous déclarez vous pas
les manifestations à la fin vous êtes
toujours menacés et vous êtes inondé le
gaz lacrymo vous pouvez vous prendre des
ailes bd etc
c'est là que généralement d'ailleurs il
ya des drames et ça honnêtement ça c'est
inadmissible mais je crois que c'est
vraiment volontaire je crois que c'est
vraiment pour essayer de dissuader au
maximum les gens d'aller dans la rue de
donner plus de force à ce mouvement
j'aurais dire qu'en parallèle voyez
quand on quand on on dit en parallèle
qu' il ya des violences magie des
violences politiques et qu'effectivement
je n'aime pas le terme en plus de
violence policière parce que ça amalgame
tout le monde il ya beaucoup une très
grande majorité de grands républicains
et professionnels évidemment dans nos
forces de l'ordre
mais d'un côté on a quand même un
pouvoir dont on a le sentiment qu'il
tient beaucoup parce la force pure ce
qui est quand même très mauvais en
démocratie l'autre côté j'ai fait le
compte l'autre jour puisque la décennie
est terminée 2010-2019 0 référendum en
france 0 on avait eu deux dans la
décennie précédente sur le quinquennat
puis la constitution européenne est
encore le deuxième a été annulée par le
parlement mais voyez 0 référendum et en
parallèle on a ce genre de cocotte
minute qui explose je pense que ça c'est
pas la seule explication mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même un lien et et que
quand le peuple a le sentiment qu'ils
s'expriment pour rien qui n'est plus
écouté ils votent pour rien eh bien ça
donne de la tension d'un côté et ça peut
donner aussi les phénomènes violents de
l'autre il faut quand même le au bout
d'un moment le réaliser et surtout
trouver une issue politique à cela au
delà des mots il faut prendre des
décisions maintenant urgemment très
concrète parce que sinon dans ça va
durer extrêmement temps peut-être qu'on
commencera l'an prochain le l'acte 115
aurélie euros est ce qu'aujourd'hui le
peuple manifeste pour rien il ya eu
l'acte 62 des gilets jaunes aujourd'hui
demain on sait qu'il ya une
manifestation contre la loi bioéthique
est ce qu'ils vont être entendus est ce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on descend dans la
rue ça sert à quelque chose
je ne pense pas qu'ils ne manifestent
pour rien mais je pense qu'ils
manifestent de manière relativement
individualiste dans l'eure dans leur
demander dans leurs préoccupations c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que vous n'avez pas
une ligne complète sur un sujet et qu'il
se hisse amalgame à d'autres
manifestations
je crois que ces manifestations
effectivement ne s'arrêteront pas durant
tout le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron si
la politique ne change pas vous parler
de référendum référendum on a un exemple
d'un référendum à notre dame des landes
et on en a vu le résultat
il ya eu un choix des citoyens et
l'application a été le contraire
donc effectivement ce type de pratiques
n'est plus possible
ils manifestent pour être entendus ils
manifestent pour être reconnu pour que
leur voix
enfin compte la démocratie
représentative ils ont l'impression de
ne plus du tout est représenté par les
politiques
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez la
classe politique vous n'avez pas toutes
les catégories socio professionnelles
représentées ou les catégories sociales
d'ailleurs en général représenté vous
avez une caste politique donc qui
considère que 90 % des français
considèrent que les politiques font de
la politique uniquement pour leurs
propres intérêts sans en dit beaucoup
sur l'état de la france
ça en dit beaucoup sur ce que pensent
les français des politiques dont je fais
partie également puisque je fais de la
politique je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut que toute la classe politique
s'interroge s'interroge échange ces
pratiques si on veut arrêter des
manifestants
si on veut arrêter de voir des gens qui
sont malheureux parce que les gilet
jaune à l'origine pourquoi ils mettaient
un chasuble jaune c'est parce que
c'était les invisibles de la république
donc il faut entendre ce message qui est
un message fort je crois que
effectivement les black blocks qui
viennent troubler ce message
n'est pas à leur avantage et c'est bien
dommage je crois qu'il faut les entendre
et changer cette cette pratique de la
politique en france
je vous propose de revenir sur cet
événement maintenant cet incendie qui
est au coeur des interrogations le
restaurant parisien la rotonde qui a été
détruit cette nuit par les flammes la
rotonde on le sert un lieu prisé par le
chef de l'état on se souvient c'est là
bas qu'il avait fêté sa victoire au
premier tour des présidentielles est la
piste privilégiée est celle de l'acte
volontaire selon une source proche de
l'enquêté la sûreté territoriale de
paris est chargée du dossier
la réaction je vous propose d'écouter la
réaction du cogérant de cette brasserie
il est abattu par les conséquences de
l'incendié écouter le feu cette nuit à
5h05 j'ai été réveillé par la service de
vidéosurveillance que nous avons là
larmes parce qu'il y avait une intrusion
dans l'établissement et donc ils m'ont
appelé ils m'ont réveillé et monde il ya
également un incendie et donc voilà je
me suis levé du coup je me suis levé je
suis venu sur place et les pompiers
étaient déjà là et on a constaté qu' il
y avait une vitre qui avait été cassée
et qu'ils avaient mis le feu et que le
feu qu'ils avaient mis le feu à la
console en droit ici et les pompiers
soient réhabilités voyons comment ça
s'est passé
c'est arrivé entre 4h30 et 5h du matin
on n'a pas une idée de qui que ce soit
on avait reçu plusieurs fois des menaces
verbales et puis mais on se doute quand
même que c'est criminel parce qu'il ya
une vie qui a été cassé
donc c'est pas un accident électrique
une enquête est en cours mais je pense
qu'elle confirmera ce qu on est abattus
aux lectrices et pour moi ça d'actes
lâches parce que voilà c'est fait la
nuit à personne sait pas qui c'est
qu'après ça j'espère que la police doit
les retrouver mais on est tous abattu il
ya 40 personnes qui travaillent ici à
peu près un peu plus et voilà ces
personnes vont se retrouver au chômage
et voilà acte 2 62 des gilets jaunes on
le disait donc ce samedi à paris selon
les chiffres de la préfecture trente
sept personnes ont été interpellées
aujourd'hui à noter un cette dispersion
compliqué de la manifestation des gilets
jaunes qui sont arrivés il y à un peu
plus d'une heure maintenant au terminus
de cette manifestation gare de lyon et
c'est là que la tension est montée d'un
cran entre manifestants et forces de
l'ordre
jets de projectiles sur la police qui a
répliqué à coups de gaz la prive de gaz
lacrymogène par dont les pompiers sont
aussi intervenus à plusieurs reprises
pour éteindre des feux voilà pour les
dernières informations sur la dispersion
de cet acte 62 du mouvement des gilets
jaunes un acte 62 sur lequel on échange
avec vous aurez bureau et florian
philippot à vos côtés autre événement
hier on en a parlé aussi beaucoup
aujourd'hui ce sont ces militants qui
ont attendu le président de la
république à la sortie de ce théâtre
dans le nord de paris
est-ce que selon vous c'est au fond une
action d'un groupuscule de militants et
ça s'arrête là un acte isolé ou en
réalité ça révèle quelque chose d'un peu
plus profond dans la société et florian
philippot c'est toujours les deux si
vous voulez c'est toujours ce genre
d'acte c'est toujours un acte limité
très marquée propre politiquement la
plupart du temps enfin là je pense que
c'est à la vue la personne qui a lancé
l'alerté à l'intérieur quand même bien
connu c'est plutôt marquée à l'extrême
gauche bon et c'est au total quelques
dizaines de personnes
et en même temps quand on prend un peu
de champ et de hauteur et qu'on regarde
la multiplication de ce genre d'actes
peut-être qu'on y mettra la rotonde
dedans je ne sais pas je fais pallancata
vent mais c'est par contre cela retombe
c'est la oumma kron avait fêté son sont
pros de manière décrié d'ailleurs la
victoire face à sur la qualification en
tout cas le soir du premier tour c'est
pour ça que dexia site des
interrogations voilà donc si vous voulez
quand on prend un peu de champ et de
hauteur on se dit et en même temps ça a
une signification
politique quand je dis ça je ne justifie
pas j'essaie vraiment c'est un peu je
suis sur une ligne de crête
je moi je suis coup toutes les violences
que les choses soient très claires et je
n'aime pas vivre dans la société dans
laquelle nous vivons actuellement je
trouve que c'est c'est une société qui
est pleine de stress de deux
d'incertitude et qui n'est pas propice à
ce que les gens puissent vivre
normalement ou même entreprendre et je
pense que nous nous nous allons nous
sommes dans des temps compliquée mais en
mai les phénomènes historiques se passe
toujours comme cela il ya des symboles
il ya la multiplication d'actes isolés
qui en fait quand on prend du champ ou
un sens politique et moi je pense que le
premier responsable de cela et celui qui
peut éteindre cela c'est le pouvoir en
lui-même la condition qu'il écoute son
peuple il faut qu'ils comprennent que la
république ça veut pas dire une petite
caste en eau qui décide tout pour tout
le monde croyant qu'elle sait mieux que
tout le monde c'est faux ça ça c'est
complètement faux et ses décors et les
gros avait parfaitement raison en disant
en plus c'est encore plus vrai à l'ère
numérique aujourd'hui où les gens
peuvent apprendre beaucoup de choses se
connecter c'est incroyable on n'a jamais
été autant connecté on peut on peut
dialoguer on peut apprendre on peut se
cultiver on peut s'instruire on peut
s'informer y compris dans le monde
entier et on n'a jamais été aussi peu
respectée je disais c'est quand même la
seule décennie on a eu aucun référendum
national
c'est quand même la décennie où on a eu
le sentiment que le vote servait le
moins moi je crois que c'est très lié à
notre implication dans l'union
européenne mais je ré ouvre pas le débat
est donc cette ce fossé qui se creuse
il crée les violences alors ça peut
créer des événements comme les bouffes
parisiens voilà ce qui s'est passé dans
le théâtre ou en soi bah on trouve pas
ça très heureux c'est pas bien d'aller
chercher le chef de l'état ou de vouloir
le vouloir du mal je vais en personne
très peu seront d'accord avec cela et en
même temps ces instances politiques il
faut pas croire que ça va s'arrêter moi
je pense que ça ne peut que se
multiplier si le gouvernement change pas
si le pouvoir reste comme il est aurelio
vous écoute dans un instant mais avant
va retrouver r estelle farges qui a
suivi pour nous tout au long de la
journée cet acte 62 des gilets jaunes
estelle bonsoir donc on le disait un le
cortège est arrivée gare de lyon où
s'est terminée la marche la situation
s'est ensuite compliqué quelle est la
situation actuellement à proximité de la
gare de lyon estelle et bien écoutez
olivier le calme est revenu en place de
la nation où je me trouve il ya tout de
même quelques véhicules des forces de
l'ordre stationnées en vous allez
pouvoir le voir derrière moi sur ces
images de et stéphane puccini alors vous
l'avez dit tout un petit peu dégénéré
lorsque le cortège est arrivée gare de
lyon où des heurts ont éclaté entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre
une fois que le gros du cortège a été
dispersée et bien un cortège sauvage
s'il vous plaît s'est formée au niveau
de la gare de lyon se cantet sauvage il
a déambulé tout au long de ce boulevard
du boulevard diderot où des barricades
ont été formés des on a vu de nombreux
feux de poubelles qui ont été est
déclenché et ce cortège sauvage et bien
il a terminé sa course ici à la jonction
entre la place de la nation et le
boulevard diderot pour ensuite eh bien
ce est dispersée en tout cas ici
situation anormale où je me trouve voilà
ce que je te veux dire olivier s'il vous
plaît ce que je peux vous dire olivier
au moment où je vous parle
merci beaucoup estelle pour tous ces
précisions et el farj donc en direct à
proximité de la gare de lyon
là où le l'acte 62
des gilets jaunes c'est terminé on en a
parlé un tout au long de sa soirée avec
vous aurélie dreux est avec vous florian
philippot peut être un mot pour conclure
il nous reste quelques minutes au terme
de cet acte 62 au terme d'une semaine
sociale très chargé on a entendu la
grogne de beaucoup de professions quel
est votre intuition pour pour la suite
on a deux mois des élections municipales
comment est ce que vous sentez le pays
avant ces élections libres alors je
pense qu'il faut séparer les deux choses
il ya les élections municipales où
chaque français se sent à mon sens très
concerné puisqu'il ya un taux de
participation qui est généralement
record qui est le plus fort taux de
participation de toutes les élections et
bravo et que ça continue comme ça parce
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui les élus
municipaux ne sont pas considérés comme
des politiques politique politiciens et
tant mieux en tout cas que les français
seraient intéressants au débat public au
sein de leur commune concernant
ce qu'on peut ressentir en france
effectivement on va pas dire qu'on est
dans un pays au pays de candy où tout
est merveilleux
clairement la france subit des
manifestations à répétition nous avons
l'égide et jaune depuis un an et demi
nous avons eu les manifestations sur la
réforme des retraites c'est vrai que ce
qui est gênant c'est que c'est très
personnalisé autour de la personnalité
du président de la république
emmanuel macron je crois que la
situation de la france hélas va bien
plus mal que depuis trois ans a fait ça
fait dix ans que ça va très mal en
france voire 20 ans je pense que
réellement c'est l'échec de la classe
politique l'échec des partis politiques
et on le voit d'ailleurs dans ces
parties ces grands partis qui était le
ps et les républicains qui ont quand
même subi des pertes massives de
militants je crois que les français
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils ne veulent plus
c'est de la politique au mauvais sens du
terme
ils veulent de la politique au sens vie
de la cité et il faut revenir à cela et
moi j'en appelle au gouvernement et au
président de la république qui je ne
doute pas sera l'entendre à un moment
donné eh bien merci beaucoup à tous les
deux orignaux florian philippot d'avoir
commenté en direct cette fin de l'acte
62 c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez vous ce
sera votre émission politique police mag
présenté par magali forestier
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le wiki geoffroy deux frères animé par
leur passion pour l'eau